une candidature du président ivoirien
dénoncées également apparition plusieurs
dizaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées aujourd'hui place du
trocadéro elles ont réclamé la
libération des prisonniers politiques
ainsi que le retour de l'ancien
président laurent gbagbo est privé de
passeport ivoirien il est actuellement
en liberté conditionnelle en belgique
écoutez ces quelques réactions de
manifestants parisiens
nous constatons que le président en
place est en train de violer
complètement ici la constitution qui est
le socle même qu'un pays et nous sommes
ici donc pour dit non à un troisième
mandat satie soit la raison de troisième
mandat n'a pas sa place parce que lui
même sa propre constitution qui la
recherche en 2016
parlant d'une troisième république ne
lui donne pas assez a fait 3-0 attachés
nous voulons que tous les présidents
africains passent d'un mandat ces deux
monarques est bon parce que avec deux
mandats et ça permet la démocratie en en
fuite
ça permet aussi à d'autres à d'autres de
ne pas faire deux mandats
et ça ça diminue aussi la guerre